well ladies and gentlemen if the polls
are to be believed the Democratic party
may be in the middle of a disastrous
collapse where for the first time in a
very very long time the 538 Senate
forecast not the house the Senate
forecast has by a very small margin
Republicans now favored to take the
Senate as you might remember for a very
long time for months it looked like two
to one even three to one odds that
Democrats would keep the Senate but
probably lose the house things have
shifted and shifted and shifted to the
point where now if we are to believe the
polling and we will look at that in more
detail
the most likely scenario is Republicans
definitely take the house
and maybe even take the Senate uh by a
52 to 48 margin
Republicans now very slightly favored to
take the Senate it's basically a dead
heat but a far cry from the 70 plus
percent odds that Democrats had to keep
the Senate just some months ago if we
look at the 538 forecast of how the odds
have changed you will see that yes back
in Late July
um it was basically 50 50. and then
Democrats building building building a
lead all the way up to about a 71 chance
of take of holding the senate in mid to
late September and a collapse to where
now it is Republicans favored to take
the Senate over in the house the numbers
even more dismal for Democrats now and
84 chance that Republicans will win the
house if we look at how those numbers
have changed over time you similarly see
that it was getting closer there for a
period in early October
still roughly a two to one margin for
Republicans but now just completely out
of reach 84 percent chance 84 percent
chance for Republicans of taking the
house
one question that many of you have asked
you came to me some of you with tears in
your eyes and said sir can we trust the
polling it is absolutely the case that
when you look at a lot of the generic
ballots which aren't looking at
individual races but they these are
generic Republican or Democratic support
in for example the House vote it is true
that there are some right-wing pollsters
sprinkled in
um Trafalgar for example which has
Republicans plus six that's a
right-leaning poll
Rasmussen is a right-leaning poll and it
has Republicans plus seven but many of
what are considered highly rated
non-politically partisan pollsters also
have Republicans leading but by a
slightly smaller margin CNN NPR Wall
Street Journal CBS News all have
Republicans leading but between two and
four in that Congressional ballot so the
most important thing to be asking is
what does this mean for what you should
do what does this mean for what I should
do and it means that we should vote just
worry about you you have one vote
make sure that you use it I have one
vote I will sure as hell make sure that
I am using it and then in six days six
and a half days seven days it'll be
Wednesday morning
um we will all have a very clear picture
of where this all shakes out but I would
be lying to you and I know every time
whenever I do this people write to me
and they say David you bastard
you're discouraging people from voting
by saying Democrats have lost
well I'm not saying Democrats have lost
I'm saying the polling is looking
increasingly bad it's actually a reason
to vote this should encourage people to
vote and then when Democrats are leading
and I report that people write to me and
they say David you bastard you're going
to make Democratic voters
um complacent where they'll say hey
we've got it we don't need to vote and
no no matter what I'm telling you we
should all vote but there are some
really bad looking numbers Oregon for
example there has not been a republican
governor in Oregon or Oregon as the
former president likes to say Oregon
hasn't had a democratic a republican
Governor since 1987. that's like a
hundred years roughly
um think of that we now have a
republican gubernatorial candidate in
Oregon that is favored to win not by a
crazy amount but slightly favored to win
now let's address a couple of issues
related to this first of all I get right
Wingers I see them on the YouTube
comments I see them on my Twitter I see
them on Twitch and they are very much up
in my email
uh gloating as if I personally
have some particular stake in this that
nobody else has just because I have a
program
um I'm gonna tell you guys this again
I will do better in terms of my business
and my show if Republicans win
everything so much like you all were
coming to me in 2016 and gloating about
Trump and much like many of you were
coming to me in 2020 and saying Joe
Biden's going to lose which by the way
you were wrong about I don't know what
these folks are really gloating about
because I have my one vote I have no
special extra votes just because I do a
show and again
I want what's best for the country
what's best for my business is that
Republicans win everything all the time
and Trump comes back and they take the
house and they take the Senate and they
take everything okay I don't want that
but the gloating is kind of weird
because it's just neither here nor there
okay that's number one number two why is
this happening we have a combination of
things
one
again
I just tell things the way I see them
Democrats are terrible on messaging just
absolutely terrible Democrats have
mostly ignored since the Roe v Wade
decision what we know year in and year
out are important economic concerns and
have minimized them to a great degree
now on my show I just give you the
numbers and I say hey you know what
extremely low unemployment nearly full
employment
inflation is high but it's flattening
and it will come down I I just give you
the numbers right but I'm not running a
campaign Democrats went in a little too
hard on Roe v Wade as the defining issue
of the election as I told you over the
summer
the timing may not actually work the
importance of Roe v Wade's repeal May
fade by November 8th and indeed that
seems to be happening and there is a
lack of a sort of escape hatch at this
point for many Democrats who have moved
to the side some of the some of the
economic concerns now a lot of those
economic concerns are based in
misunderstandings like for example that
the economy is a disaster the economy is
doing pretty well gas prices down uh
unemployment very high new job creation
High I've told but what matters is the
perception of the economy
and by hammering on it Republicans made
have made significant Headway in
addition to that typically
the party that wins the White House gets
crushed in the following midterms it
looked like maybe 2022 would be an
exception but things are reverse uh are
coming back to it's a regression to the
mean you might call it historically it
should be a bad election cycle for
Democrats so that's the combination of
what's going on we will have the real
numbers very soon but if we're going to
lose I want to lose fairly and that
means no armed intimidation of Voters at
the drop boxes and we've got to talk
about that next a judge has ordered
armed gunmen away from ballot drop boxes
but not all the way away
just 250 feet away you're allowed to
intimidate at ballot drop boxes in
Arizona as long as you do it from 250
feet away
if you have been following this story as
we have we started to see
armed what do we call them they're armed
so they are gunmen is it a militia I
don't know not really armed people
claiming to be poll Watchers
showing up in and around ballot drop
boxes in Arizona in some cases we have
video of confrontations with people just
dropping off ballots of course
immediately
um the courts were brought into this and
HuffPost and the Associated Press now
report judge orders armed group away
from Arizona ballot drop boxes local and
federal law enforcement have been
alarmed by reports of people some armed
watching 24-hour ballot boxes in two
counties
and a federal judge yesterday ordered
the armed members of this group to stay
at least
250 feet away from the locations
following complaints that people wearing
masks all of a sudden they want to wear
masks and carrying guns were
intimidating voters wow U.S District
Court Judge Michael Liberty also said
members of clean elections USA its
leader and anyone working with them are
barred from filming or following anyone
within 75 feet of a ballot Dropbox or
the entrance of a building that houses
one they also can't speak to or yell at
people within that perimeter unless
spoken to First
this is insanity
this is absolute and Total Insanity
armed people monitoring dropboxes it is
a dystopian laughing stock but we kind
of laugh to avoid crying which is really
what we should be doing this is horrible
this is you know I don't want to use
pejorative terms Third World stuff or
whatever this is completely Unbecoming
of the United States and by the way they
can be there they just have to be 250
feet away
it should have happened sooner and it
should be more than 250 feet understand
that 250 feet in many cases means that
they're allowed to be
at the entrance at the sort of driveway
what it was the parking lot I guess what
you would call it at the entrance to the
parking lot to the to the uh locations
of these ballot drop boxes it doesn't
even really change anything often you
have a couple hundred feet particularly
in Arizona where things are so spread
out in many parts of the state so
instead of seeing them right by the
Dropbox itself you see the armed people
as you're driving in to where you would
stop to put your ballots in
uh apparently the intimidation with guns
is okay and it's free speech as long as
you're 250 feet away now there's a real
question here
this has had a chilling effect already
is the court decision too late because
at the end of the day they're simply
being told you've got to be a little
further away and they still might have
had the impact that they want to have
but this should scare all of us and
Arizona is the big state in which we've
learned about this happening for now I
am monitoring for stories of it
happening in other states and if you
come across any please do let me know
but this is you know the the court is
determining whether what is being done
violates the letter of the law
what I am more concerned with is that
all of this and this dates back to six
months before the 2020 election when
they started to hint that if we lose
it's rigged and the mail-in ballots are
fraud and all this different stuff the
the spirit of what it should be to have
an election in the United States of
America has of course been violated by
all of this nonsense going all the way
back let me know what you think find me
on Twitter at dpacman we'll take a very
quick break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show is a viewer and
listener funded program I would really
love it particularly at this critical
critical time for Independent Media as
we have a very important election coming
and an even more important election
potentially after that I would love for
you to sign up at joinpakman.com you can
use the coupon code big voting22 for six
more days get the discount get the bonus
show the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad get all
of it thank your lucky stars every day
you're not Dave Pacman and you still
won't be Dave Pacman sign up at
joinpakman.com would love to see you
there I told you yesterday or the day
before or like three weeks ago I don't
know time flies that Donald Trump had
one last chance left to prevent his tax
returns from being released to the house
committee investigating him and that
last opportunity was an appeal to the
highest court of the land the Supreme
Court a very a right-wing Court in 2022
the Supreme Court has decided to pray at
the altar of trump and indeed judge
Justice John Roberts has delayed the
Handover of Donald Trump's taxes to that
house panel this was the last arrow in
the quiver that Trump had left
and indeed it is on target at least
temporarily the Associated Press
reporting Roberts delays Handover of
trump tax returns to house panel amazing
right but maybe not totally surprising
Chief Justice John Roberts on Tuesday
put a temporary hold on the Handover of
Trump's tax returns to the Congressional
committee Robert's order gives the
Supreme Court time to weigh the legal
issues in Trump's emergency appeal to
the high court filed Monday without
Court intervention the tax returns could
have been provided as early as Thursday
by the treasury Department to the
democratically controlled house Ways and
Means Committee Roberts gave the
committee until wait a second November
10th
why is that an important date let me
think November 10th oh there's an
election on November 8th very
interesting the Chief Justice handles
emergency appeals from the nation's
capital where the fight over Trump's
taxes has been going on since 2019
writes the Associated Press remember
lower courts ruled that the committee
has brought authority to obtain tax
returns and rejected Trump's claim that
it was overstepping
um this is uh it are we shocked by this
CNBC also reporting Supreme Court
temporarily blocks Congress from getting
Trump's tax returns
um a very very similar report from CNBC
uh what exactly is going to happen with
this because for years the house Ways
and Means Committee which has absolutely
appropriate
uh constitutionally indicated
investigative responsibilities not just
abilities but responsibilities has been
doing everything correctly and trying to
get a hold of these taxes they've done
everything and it's appeal and obstruct
and block if indeed at this point Donald
Trump didn't think that there was going
to be something damaging to him in those
tax returns why would he still be
working this hard to block their release
what also by the way is the
Constitutional question that the Supreme
Court needs to weigh and think about
where every other judge and court so far
has said no there's no good argument
here the house has brought authority to
obtain tax returns they are doing
everything correctly they should be
turned over every single court has found
that in every venue that Donald Trump
has figured out how to pull into this
mess
but the Supreme Court now needs time
until just 36 hours after the midterm
elections
figure out whether this is actually
appropriate or not November 10th for the
committee to reply what is the purpose
of the block what determines whether the
block stays and how long does it
actually last is this just a Brazen
attempt to get beyond the November 8th
election
without the tax returns being released
no matter what is in there just on the
off chance that there's something
damaging to Trump or Republicans there
could the Supreme Court be that biased
politically to the right given that it
has three trumpous judges on it even
though this was the decision of a
Justice not selected by Donald Trump
Chief Justice John Roberts at this point
I genuinely don't know
but when you read sober
political legal analyzes of this
all of those analyzes come to the
conclusion that at the end of the day
the tax returns should be given to the
house Ways and Means Committee whether
they will find anything
noteworthy there remains to be seen as a
reminder
three most likely elements that would
come from a full review of Donald
Trump's tax returns if indeed they are
provided in full and under adapted would
be number one Trump's not as wealthy as
he claims to be we basically know that
already but it would be confirmation
number two it would confirm what Michael
Cohen and others have been saying for a
long time that for tax purposes Trump
undervalues assets that he separately
overvalues when they are to be used for
collateral purposes that would be number
two
um and then uh I mean and we could go
even further there's many other things I
won't repeat to you the entire list but
the point here is the things we are
likely to learn would not come as an
insane shock but they would be
confirmation of what we've suspected for
a long time also I guess I should
mention that Donald Trump has business
with Shady characters that would be
another and how would we learn that well
he may list assets on tax returns which
we could then cross-reference to other
owners or other business entities that
are involved in the ownership of the
very same assets it would show that
Trump is in business with people we
didn't know about or that he sought to
downplay or whatever the case may be do
I believe that ultimately the house
committee will get the tax returns I do
and by the way I expect them to leak
once the house committee gets them but
it could take a little bit longer Donald
Trump appeared yesterday on the Chris
Stiegel podcast I have no idea what that
is but these are the sorts of interviews
that the failed former president is now
relegated to doing Trump's brain broke
it it acutely broke it almost made a
noise like a clanking noise when it
broke that's a joke Trump repeating the
now widely debunked conspiracy theories
about the attacker of Paul Pelosi Trump
saying that he once made rough
statements on Jewish what does that mean
I have no idea what the hell this guy is
talking about look at the breakdown
of this man's brain starting with the
first clip Trump asked about the assault
on Paul Pelosi listen to what Trump said
how do you read what's happened in the
Pelosi household in San Francisco over
the weekend by the way why do all of
these right Wingers
have the Alex Jones voice Batman's a
loser why do they all talk like Alex
Jones topic for a different day well
it's a weird things going on in that
household in the last couple of weeks uh
you know I probably you and I are better
not talking about it because but the
last it seems was broken from the inside
to the out why and you know that was so
it wasn't a break-in it was a breakout I
don't know you know you hear the same
things I do yeah the 911 tape seems to
suggest that uh they that he knew the
identity of the guy yeah yeah uh
that's a lot of bad stuff I'm not a fan
of Nancy Pelosi but what's going on
there is very sad yeah I just it seems
to me there would be security evidence
of this there just seems to be more of
this story would it would it be safe to
say this is I think more than the
traffic accident
on Republicans or you sir I mean how
absurd clearly this was a deranged man
we know that much
yeah it's the whole thing is crazy I
mean if there's even a little bit of
Truth to what's being said it's crazy
but if the window was broken in and it
was strange that the cops were the you
know standing there practically they
didn't from the moment it all took place
so listen
Trump repeated these claims yesterday
November 1st after we already had
information about all of these claims
the attacker himself confirmed all of
what we now know to be true uh the cops
didn't just stand there they very
quickly found the guy the glass was not
broken From the Inside Out yes there
were pieces of Glass on the outside
imagine taking a hammer to a glass
window every time you pull it back
towards you to hammer it again you pull
a little bit of glass out it's not a big
shock that there was glass on the
outside uh Pelosi didn't say I know the
guy it appears as though in order to
keep the guy calmer while on the phone
with 9-1-1 he said something like my
friend here but he did not literally
mean I know the guy the guy is known to
me the attacker already said he had had
no previous contact with Pelosi
um Pelosi was in his underwear because
he sleeps in his underwear and it was
two in the morning there were security
cameras that recorded every single one
of these lies already debunked but this
is nothing then during the Chris stigl
interview they get to the topic of Kanye
West and Trump says
he made rough statements on Jewish
I I know you're saying David are you are
you missing a word there what do you
mean
listen do you think Kanye West is
getting a fair Shake I always thought
after he aligned with you even for a
while uh he was a Marked Man no matter
what he said or done since uh he you
know he's been on the Tucker Carlson
show as you know how do you read Kanye
West these days well I I was very
honored when I was because I didn't know
him that well but I liked him I always
get along with him very well and I was
very honored in a sense because he uh
you know he said all those great things
about being Tucker Carlson
uh by the way that's what matters if he
said good things about Trump Trump's
going to defend him made some statements
rough statements uh on Jewish rough
statements on Jewish
I might once made rough statements on an
Apple I was sitting on the Apple it was
weird you heard them and you know them
well yes and uh they're saying that that
was the reason
uh so then you ask well would it have
been the same thing if he didn't say all
those good things about Trump you know
you just don't know
um he'll be fine I think he'll be fine
he's a very different kind of a guy yes
and uh it was very interesting to hear
mataka Carlson because you know you
never hear him in long sentences right
they also cut out a bunch of
anti-Semitic stuff from the Tucker
interview too he was actually very sharp
and very uh very smart I was I was
impressed by a lot of what he said well
they talked about life he talked about
health these are things that he feels
the black community is being lied to
about those things he does he feels it
and man it's it's all about what have
you done for me lately Kanye has praised
Trump so Trump's gonna say listen he
made rough statements on Jewish whatever
that means but he's pretty brilliant I
liked a lot of the things he said Trump
confirms he won't go back to Twitter in
the context of his own platform truth
essential yeah if I go on there what
would happen to truth I don't know you
know I I don't know but but the edge is
I'm not doing it right I woke up back on
and but I find truth to be much better
it's smarter it's friendlier and also
can be very nasty yeah oh yes especially
if they get against you a little bit
even your own people if they disagree
with something you did they
Trump's talking about vaccines there
yeah we got some smart ones but it's
it's tremendous and it was number one
for the last couple of weeks it's
incredible how well yeah so Donald Trump
his own platform which he often gets the
name wrong of Truth Central he says he's
sticking with truth and not going back
on Twitter and lastly Trump playing with
the supply chain games remember when
Trump used to love to say the cupboards
were bare and all this different stuff
now he's saying there's no turkeys this
shouldn't be in this country and I can't
help but feel like it's purposeful sir
sir is that your read
well it's certainly a terrible thing and
it certainly shouldn't be and supply
chain shouldn't be in this country
either I mean Pierce you know just basic
supply chain now I understand you can't
get turkey you can't get turkey now
Trump understands folks listen this
interview was on November 1st who is
buying a turkey on November 1st for a
November 24th Thanksgiving now sure if
you've got a huge freezer or something I
know some people will buy the turkey on
November 1st every place I'm seeing is
scheduling the turkey pickups for like
Monday Tuesday and Wednesday of
Thanksgiving week that's number one and
then number two I've just been to two
different grocery stores this week
they're filled with turkeys there's
turkeys bursting out of everywhere I
tried to get avocados there were turkeys
there I tried to get you know uh I tried
to get whatever anyway there's turkeys
everywhere at this point in time Trump
relegated
to completely frothing at the mouth
friendly interviews on podcasts no one's
ever heard of Chris stigl and he still
doesn't make any sense let's keep
fighting this right wing nuttery by
growing Progressive Independent Media as
far as we can if you are watching these
clips on YouTube and you are not
subscribed please hit that subscribe
button I know many of you say David sir
I see all your Clips I don't need to
subscribe do me the favor because
there's almost three million of you who
watch the clips but don't subscribe if
we were to get to 2 million YouTube
subscribers it would be an
accomplishment held only by The Young
Turks in the Progressive media space
help us get there hit that subscribe
button I'll give you an update on our
progress next week
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's
check in on the campaign of Georgia
Republican Senate candidate Herschel
Walker if you said to me David sir what
is the race that is depressing you the
most this year
Oz fetterman would be up there
Kerry Lake Katie Hobbs would be up there
there's some others that would be up
there but near or at the top of the list
has to be the Herschel Walker story
Herschel Walker can barely speak and
can't explain his political positions in
any kind of detail on any issue but most
importantly he is now embroiled in
multiple scandals in which he is just
straight up lying he has been caught
urging and paying for multiple women to
get abortions despite claiming to be
completely against abortion abortion is
murder according to him no exceptions no
exceptions no exceptions he's urged
multiple women and paid for multiple
women to get abortions he just denies it
he's obviously lying he has claimed
multiple times to be part of law
enforcement and they're just lies he
pulled out an honorary badge at a debate
was laughed at and then keeps pulling
the back badge out he's a liar liar liar
and the new unbelievable situation is
that the second abortion accuser
has now given an interview on television
she shows her face she's being referred
to as Jane Doe it's probably only a
matter of time until the woman is
identified but she's going by Jane Doe
but it's shown her face
and she says that Herschel Walker
essentially gave her an ultimatum about
the abortion you and the hypothetical
child would not be safe
if you chose not to have this abortion
think of that
listen to this from uh ABC News he did
not want me to have the child
and he said that
he said that because of his
wife's family and powerful people
around him that I would not be safe and
that the child would not be safe
that's that's very menacing
it is a very menacing
it is very messy now
[Music]
and I felt
threatened and I
I
thought I had no choice think about them
think about that if that is true this
guy is an absolute monster
now there is of course the hypocrisy
element to this
which we're going to deal with in a
moment but there is also the growing
understanding
this is not a nice guy he's threatening
the woman he impregnated and the
hypothetical child with not being safe
unless the woman gets an abortion his
own son
Christian Walker has said that he and
his mom had to move six times due to the
threats from Herschel Walker there is
nothing here that actually is meeting
the self-described standard he puts on
himself which is a great Christian man a
great father all these different there's
there's none of it whatsoever and even
if you don't care about the specifics
maybe you're a Georgia voter and you
don't care about the abortion issue you
care about his view on taxes you could I
couldn't tell you what it is but you can
understand it congratulations
but don't you care about the fact that
this guy is a menace and a liar does
that not matter at this point in time
and the answer is it very well may not
and that's what we're going to look at
next
sometimes we jokingly use the term brain
worms
and what we mean so sometimes by brain
worms is
somebody's abilities to think critically
and consistently
are either suspended deliberately or
just not functioning we finally got a
very interesting interview Fox
interviewed a supporter of Georgia
Republican Senate candidate Herschel
Walker
and they actually asked her
what about the fact that he paid for an
abortion for a woman he urged to get the
abortion after he impregnated her
uh what about that because this woman is
presumably pro-life anti-choice
anti-abortion
and he claims to be as well
and she says we've all done things when
we were young
Herschel Walker was a nearly 50 year old
man when this happened when we were
young he's 60 now he was almost 50 when
he did this
what the hell are you talking about and
this is an example of the total
cognitive dissonance that exists and the
inability to reach certain people which
is where I'm going to focus in here but
let's take a look at this clip okay
matter to you if it's true or not
I know as long as he is
had a change of heart
I mean we all do things when we're young
naive
he's an adult now yeah he was an adult
of nearly 50 years of age
when he impregnated a woman
urged her to get an abortion paid for
the abortion and now in the second case
that we now know of
implicitly and menacingly threatened the
woman he impregnated by saying you would
not be safe if you did not get an
abortion and the eventual child would
not be safe if you didn't get an
abortion so there's a bunch of different
stories here let's talk about them first
is the
realization
that many of us have had you really
can't reason with these voters right
what if that woman who we just saw the
interview with
she straight up says eh he's changed his
mind and he did this when he was young
we all do things when we were young he
was almost 50. okay you can't reason
with her so what do you have to do
you have to take the money that you
might spend trying to reach those people
and instead you have to Target rational
people
to just get them out to vote so as a
political strategy we've said before
where do you spend limited resources uh
how do you invest the resources and time
that you have is it on trying to change
the minds of people like that woman
seems quite fruitless I think you would
agree at least from an election story
interpersonally sure try to talk sense
into her but as far as we have X number
of dollars to spend do we try to just
get out the vote from people who already
lean in our direction or do we try to
change the minds of people like that
you've got to just try to get people to
vote that are already that are not
totally Bamboozled and disconnected from
reality like that woman that's number
one number two this idea of redemption
this is an extraordinary get out of jail
free card for the right which is
important for us to understand
Redemption can be used to explain away
any transgression no matter what as long
as the individual has completely
implausibly repented or said why they've
changed their mind and it's used by the
right to never have to actually consider
voting for a Democrat to never consider
that the Democrat may actually be the
better choice as Raphael Warnock is in
the state of Georgia we saw this with
Trump Donald Trump
68 years of life pro-choice
all of a sudden he's running to be the
Republican Presidential nominee and he
needs some way to no longer be
pro-choice that people will believe
Trump comes up with the completely
unbelievable story well you know I was
very pro-choice my whole life this is
Trump's story okay I was I used to be
pro-choice
but I met a woman what a kid
and I met the kid and it was a great kid
and the woman said you know at one point
I wasn't sure if it was the right thing
to have this pregnancy to carry this
pregnancy to term I thought about
getting an abortion and I didn't and
Trump goes you know what my 68 years of
being pro-choice I flushed him down the
toilet 10 to 15 times because I met a
kid I liked
that's the story
I don't believe that that's an absurd
story
I know many of you don't believe that
story but it's a get out of jail free
card for the right Wingers who go he saw
the light eventually yes it took him 68
years but he eventually Saw the Light
um on religion we know Trump is not
religious we know Trump has no idea
about religion he didn't go grow up
religious or any of it but he started
saying I love the Bible oh really Mr
President there at the time he wasn't
president Mr Trump sir uh what's your
favorite passage oh that's personal I
don't want to get into that do you
believe that do you believe that Trump
is a Bible guy well are you a first
amend a First Amendment are you a uh a
new testament or an Old Testament guy uh
both oh okay
completely unbelievable but the
Evangelical right eventually came around
and said well
he came he eventually figured out the
right position on abortion and he's
religious now and he loves the Bible and
blah blah blah so the Redemption story
is a blank slate get out of jail free
card if they want it
if they want it if they want to bury you
then they don't use the Redemption story
but as long as you've said I changed my
mind they completely uncritically accept
it if it's convenient now let's kind of
go to the last thing
speaking very
narrowly and specifically
people like this have a driver's license
how do people like this hold a job like
the woman who we saw there she's holding
a kid in the interview how does she
parent a child
some of these folks I genuinely don't
know how they get through the day I
don't know how they accomplish the
simplest tasks grocery shopping
uh figuring out the right amount of
Tylenol to take quite frankly I don't
know how they survive I don't because
they are so
I don't even want to characterize it
with adjectives
it's
disturbing to think about the number of
folks that are this Clueless
that just live in the country with us
and it helps us understand how Trump won
and unfortunately
why Herschel Walker may also win on
Tuesday if our Georgia friends and
neighbors don't get out to vote
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
former president Barack Obama still on
the campaign Trail still absolutely
crushing a lot of the horrible people
that are running this time around most
recently uh former president Obama was
in the state of Nevada Nevada is a place
that has a very important race going on
it is a race that is not necessarily
going that well for the Democrat the
Republican running is Adam laxalt a
horrible horrible person uh this is a
Nevada Senate and the Democratic
candidate is Catherine Cortez masto
unfortunately Adam LAX salt has opened
up a roughly two-point lead roughly
two-point lead 1.9 percentage points
over masto and he is an absolutely
horrible horrible candidate former
president Barack Obama Obama yeah right
right we know his real name he called
out the rising anti-Semitism that we are
seeing he correctly identified that the
rhetoric Rick that led to Paul Pelosi
being attacked is likely to do more
damage and to cause more violence let's
listen to a few of these clips speaking
very precisely on these issues
and
and it gets disseminated millions of
people log on to that I want to give you
a tip Nevada yep
I I I want to give you a tip if you see
or read something on the Internet
that says some people certain kinds of
people
whether it's whether it's white or black
or immigrant or
gay
or Jew
or Muslim when you see
something on the Internet that says
those people are the cause of your
problems
that that is that is a dangerous lie
[Applause]
that that
that is a path
that will tear this country apart yeah
and it's not just we'll tear the country
apart
but it's will also lead to significantly
more violence and in this next clip
former president Obama makes that point
very clear as well
a friend of mine Mr Paul Pelosi
was attacked viciously somebody broke
into his home looking for his wife Nancy
Pelosi the Speaker of the House
and thankfully I spoke to Paul a couple
days ago and I he's going to be okay
but
but it but even as investigators do
their job find out what exactly
motivated this this person one thing's
clear
this increasing habit of demonizing
political opponents
creates a dangerous climate
and and elected officials who do not
explicitly reject
or participate in over the top rhetoric
if that's what they're doing instead if
if they just ignore
or make light
of that kind of violence
or if they encourage their supporters to
stand outside voting places armed with
guns and dressed in tactical gear yes if
that's the environment that we create
more people are going to get hurt and
remember
generically condemning violence when
there is violence but then continuing to
do campaign ads where there's Targets on
people or to say at campaign rallies
someone should really do something about
Nancy Pelosi this is a really big
difference between the left and the
right in the United States
the right will say
black lives matter is violent and they
threaten people or antifa does this that
or the other thing when you look at the
top level of the people in positions of
power you do not see the violent
rhetoric from the left the way that you
see from the right
it's what it is the left doesn't talk
about knocking them around alluding to
violence but playing Coy the left
doesn't regularly use campaign ads with
people holding Firearms or putting
Targets on the backs of individuals
I know that we can find in a country of
330 million anecdotes of everything but
the right specifically the Maga right
Mitt Romney really doesn't do this that
I've ever seen him do
I've not seen Liz Cheney do it I've not
seen Adam kinzinger do it but the Maga
right
is doing this deliberately
and it's not it might lead to violence
anymore it's it has led to violence it
has led to violence Barack Obama also
weighing in very clearly on the stakes
here when it comes to policy that
affects people versus cultural issues
that are contrived and used to drive
wedges between individuals
the question though you should be asking
is who's going to actually try to do
something about it right
because if you watch these ads
Republicans they talk about it a lot but
what's their answer exactly what what is
their Economic Policy none
tax cuts for the rich I guess no no they
they've got one
they want to gut Social Security
and Medicare
and then give
their wealthy friends and big
corporations more tax cuts right
because
and because that's their answer to
everything
that's I I'm not joking literally it
does not matter what's going on
when inflation is low and unemployment
is high
they want tax cuts
when it's the reverse
tax cuts
I I was telling some folks in Michigan
if there was an asteroid heading towards
Earth right now
they'd all get in the room they say you
know what you need you we gotta cut
taxes for the wealthy
that that's going to solve it
really
I mean I guess it's simple
to just have one answer to every
economic problem exactly
I remember
you know what I when I had a test in
math and and uh sometimes I I didn't
study hard enough
might have stayed up too late the night
before and and it'd be nice if you could
just write down eight
on for every answer yeah I mean this is
just a version of when all you have is a
hammer everything looks like a nail or
you claim it's a nail even if it's
something completely different and
former president Obama is completely
right in that and he actually goes
further and again this is not about
glorifying Republicans of times past
it's not that Reagan was great or bush
by dear God it's not that Bush was great
either it's that there has been a real
observable tangible change in the way
that this political party the Republican
Party operates
on the one hand you've got politicians
who seem like they won't do anything and
say anything
to get power
and leaders who share our values who
want to make your lives better
who want to move the country forward
and and let me say this Nevada
they
you know one of the difficult things
about these kinds of rally these days is
is
sometimes
this this seems so partisan as if it's
just a Democrat Republican thing my
favorite President is a guy named Abe
Lincoln
who helped found the Republican Party
it used to be that
there were GOP members who championed
progress and civil rights and that was
longer ago than Bush to be clear
but these days just about every
Republican politician seems obsessed
with two things
owning the lips and getting Donald
Trump's approval
for now for now and as we spoke about
with Angelo Carrison yesterday
the desperation for Trump's approval May
Wane depending on how next Tuesday goes
and depending on what happens with
Trump's 2024 candidacy if there is one
last clip from Obama
he weighs in on Election fraud Adam lack
salt the candidate that he is
campaigning against in Nevada is a big
lie proponent
and here is what President Obama says
he has no actual evidence of election
fraud because
there's actually no widespread election
fraud but he's not going to let that
stop him absolutely he's gonna look
under every Rock in the desert to try to
find an excuse
although if you if he wins I'm guessing
he'll be less concerned
all those votes will be legit funny how
that works
listen I lost my first congressional
Race by 30 points I got whooped
you know you know what I did not do
I didn't say this was right
I didn't claim fraud
I certainly didn't instigate
a riot on the capitol
instead I asked myself
how can I be better yeah good luck
getting Republicans to ask themselves
that question and of course he's
completely and totally correct if you
vote in Nevada
if you vote in Nevada we do not want
Senator Adam laxalt and we have the
potential to see Senator Adam laxalt and
Senator Herschel Walker
and Senator Mehmet Oz and Governor Kerry
Lake
and a republican governor in Oregon
whose name I forget for the first time
since 1987.
this could get very dark very very
quickly and so we have to vote we have
to vote is the message I know it's
repetitive but it is a must do real
quick in one of the absolutely wildest
unhinged rants of the Mike pillow era
he went on TV after a brief Hiatus his
own show I think it's important to say
we're doing a class
yeah not that but he now is claiming to
have people and cameras watching polling
places in every County as well as
so-called cyber guys that can look
inside voting machines in real time
if he's lying then he's very ill
if he's telling the truth these are
probably crimes listen to this this
election and I'm telling everyone out
there we are
one from every anger
angry boy in every state every County
every Precinct Brandon remember you they
may think you can't look and see what's
going inside that black box but we can
now in real time through something
called The Edison report everybody right
we have cyber guys watching this we I
looked at a thing today it was on my my
Twitter back from November of 2020 and
they showed CNN 20 000 votes dropping
right off at Donald Trump's total in
real time you guys votes don't go in
reverse these are computer manipulation
algorithms so what I'm telling you is
this selection it's all eyes we have all
the camera angles now why not everyone
would say well Mike why are you telling
the bad guys right now
well I'm telling them Brad they are the
bad guys because the way I look at it
we're gonna it's gonna be a win-win
because the ones where we can override
the algorithms are going to be there
they're going to win
and then also the ones they don't all of
it we got it all under camera well maybe
this time around the judges and the the
left with the left media and maybe even
the right Media Fox News and Newsmax
will actually report if there's machines
that are involved in this election to
steal another election yeah listen I
don't know whether he thinks he's
telling the truth or whether he's
delusional or whether it is the truth
and he's admitting to crimes I don't
know about any of it but we need to get
Beyond this type of thinking for every
pillow man
there are
ten thousand fifty thousand two hundred
and fifty thousand people who literally
believe this stuff is it a million I
don't know it is a sickness it is a
sickness and for everybody who's been
asking me hey you know David Mike pillow
when you interviewed him a couple weeks
ago he said he was going to send you
some free pillows so for you to try them
did he ever do it no he did not
so that also by by the way I'm very
happy with the pillows I have but I
would have been curious to try the mic
pillows he also did not do that we have
a voicemail number that number is 2192
David P here is a caller who is not
happy with my analysis about the Kanye
West anti-Semitism situation from
yesterday listen to this
hi
um so I was watching today's episode uh
from November 1st and I found it a
little bit problematic
um how confidently
uh David speaks on the motive of where
like Kanye's anti-Semitism is absolutely
abhorrent and unacceptable no exceptions
full stop yes but you really need a
medical
um expertise of of some kind to be able
to assume that his anti-Semitism isn't
coming from the mental illness because
it's actually incredibly common uh with
bipolar type 2 and
schizophrenia that they have very
conspiratorial beliefs
um I've had friends who have gotten sick
and then gotten better and believed very
unhinged conspiratorial things you
should also keep in mind that Kanye has
a lot of distaste and a lot of distrust
for black people as well and the black
lives matter movement yeah so listen let
me address this
what is the point that I was making
yesterday think back to Mel Gibson Mel
Gibson got completely drunk and got
pulled over
and he immediately said to the cop are
you a Jew and he went on an anti-semitic
ramp
and then it was blamed on the alcohol
and one of the things that was widely
accepted at the time was drinking didn't
make Mel Gibson anti-semitic it's not
that you without being exposed to
anti-semitic conspiracy theories you
drank and suddenly you believed the Jews
controlled banking right the alcohol
can't make you it has to be in there
already and so the point with Kanye is
yes people become paranoid and
conspiratorial when they are suffering
from a number of different mental
illnesses but the things about which
they become conspiratorial aren't
planted there and what I'm saying is if
you lived outside of a society in which
anti-semitic tropes and beliefs were
perpetuated you could start suffering
from bipolar II and your paranoia would
be about the police while watching you
or something that is there already that
you are aware of you you're not all of a
sudden gonna be absent having that
information or those claims somewhere
already
you're not going to start believing
those particular things simply because
you drink too much or you start having a
manic episode or whatever the case may
be that's the point so what I there is
no doubt that we're we're Kanye
better mental health wise
he very well might not be saying these
things and might not even think them to
the degree that he does
but these are beliefs that we know have
been floating around in Kanye's head for
a long time and that's the point that I
was trying to make on the bonus show
today we will talk about jair bolsonaro
signaling he will cooperate with the
transfer of power but not conceding
defeat we're going to talk about a total
lockdown at Shanghai Disneyland in China
wild situation and we will talk about a
Democratic candidate who was beaten and
knocked unconscious in his home that's
Richard ringer this is crazy all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show sign up at joinpakman.com